yeah like Leslie said I'm really I have
a PhD in microbial ecology and
microbiology so that's when my
background really is but I got involved
in all kinds of areas of microbiology
microbial physiology and molecular
genetics including synthetic biology and
so I have a very broad background and
very broad interests and David and I got
together a while ago and we looked at
the situation of petroleum and fossil
fuels and global climate warming and
global climate change and what can
biology what does biology play a can
biology play a significant role in that
people have been looking at this long
before we had but we thought is there
anything new that we might be able to
add to the mix and is there something
novel that we might be able to do that
would make it more successful so we
thought about many things and decided
upon the technology that I'm going to
describe to you today along with our
marketing and a bit of our business
strategy and we formed a company called
Helio bios's today's I'm going to talk
about bio produced feedstocks sugars for
bio products not going to specifically
talk about anything in particular and
not about fuels because fuels biofuels
as many of you may know really have been
the focus of several companies that were
developed in the course of the last ten
years and one by one they have all
essentially reached the same endpoint in
that the biofuel a market is
extraordinarily large or that i should
say though the fuel market is
extraordinarily large extraordinarily
difficult to get into and it the
practicality of doing that is very
difficult so so a little bit about our
company we actually started with another
nonprofit who sort of sponsored us in
the very beginning the SETI Institute
and we looked for screening
cyanobacteria to produce ethanol first
idea was Wow can we just go straight to
ethanol or some kind of bio product
that and so we actually were successful
in genetically modifying Santa bacteria
to actually produce ethanol what
happened well ethanol is toxic they
killed themselves so we said okay what
else can we do to to modify it so we
decided that we would actually modify it
a little bit and we control the amount
of ethanol production and then the next
problem was okay well they are going to
produce the ethanol ethanol is highly
volatile and we lost our product in the
air I might say that concomitant with
this there's another company that
actually had the same idea called algun
all however algun all decided they were
not going to switch gears they actually
went all the way through they produce
ethanol they had this if you read their
papers and read all the information over
the years about that company they had
the same exact problems we have and so
they've developed a system now where
they grow the organisms enclosed
bioreactors constantly regulating
ethanol production and harvesting the
ethanol okay they've been at it a long
time then a little few years later we
decided we were going to leave the SETI
Institute we incorporated ourselves and
set it up set up a self-funded lab and
we developed our our cyanobacterial
consortium that i'll talk to you about
in a near future I mean in the yeah
within a few minutes characterized so
then we started to characterize our
organisms in two consortia and started
to actually try to do some scale up and
realizing that we're a small company in
just a you know two individuals we had
to really expand and develop some
partnerships so the first partnership we
developed was that was with sr I
international and there we're still
working together and then we expanded
and we're now working with the Lawrence
Berkeley Lab division of the a bpdu
which stands for advanced biofuel
product development unit we also have a
partnership with moss landing Marine Lab
which is part of the Cal State System
and a private aquaculture company called
Monterey bluewater farms
and just last year we were successful in
getting a small do II grant with the a
bpdu and we're continuing to write
proposals for outdoor scale up in sugar
characterization and I'll get to one of
the questions in a minute here towards
the end of the lecture on what our
strategy is for getting money in
addition to federal funds and what kind
of problems we have encountered when
trying to get private funding through
venture capitalists so our future is to
build partnerships and to commercialize
so basically we rely on SR I
international and Lawrence Berkeley
National Labs portal laboratories
because we can't really afford as a
small start-up to have much in the way
of a laboratory for actually scaling up
to small scale ponds which is what we're
trying to use managed pond systems up to
a few thousand gallons we've teamed up
with ma with moss landing marine lab and
then to go bigger than that to one acre
far one acre pond farms were teaming up
with monterey blue water farms and of
course then as our technology is
basically a marine based technology we
have to have a method for actually
separating out salt from our product and
we're working with company called nova
sep and a company called dow and they
both are involved in doing salt
separation from sugars on a commercial
scale and then we also as was mentioned
just previously we're also doing a
techno-economic analysis of te a also
with sr i-- Berkeley National Labs and
lifecycle Associates which is a private
company as well as NREL and a te a
basically is based on one of the things
that Leslie mentioned earlier and that
is the whole analysis of the lifecycle
of your system and i have i have an
example of that so one of the things
that we have done that most other
companies have not done is we've keyed
in on cyanobacteria so let me tell you a
little bit about
bacteria Santa bacteria have been around
a long time so they're very hearty they
were the first oxygen producing photo
synthesizers to evolve our entire
atmosphere actually came into being
without with oxygen because of them they
are distributed everywhere in the oceans
lakes rivers desert you find them
everywhere they're both marine and
freshwater they are robust that's one of
the reasons why we chose to work with
them their prolific they like to grow
they grow everywhere and they're very
well adapted to changes in the
environment and they'll grow anywhere
everywhere from the poles to the equator
you find them in desert crusts you'll
find them in the ocean you find them in
lakes and rivers and one of the things
that we really like about working with
this organism that we found interesting
and why we chose marine organisms is
because marine cyanobacteria excrete
sugars into the water they don't just
hold them inside the cell they excrete
the sugars into the water while they're
growing which really alleviates a lot of
problems associated with getting
anything out of a cell and they have the
highest photosynthetic efficiency of all
organisms known now this is just to
illustrate here and I don't have a
pointer but if you look at this
cyanobacteria evolved a long long time
ago several billion years ago and if you
look at it you see that as they grew and
grew see that line that's the blue line
in the very top in a there well they
start producing oxygen and as they grew
and they took over they really produced
a lot of oxygen and it changed the
entire as you might call it the entire
ecosystem of the earth at that time and
it wasn't it was because of these little
cyanobacteria and they're being so
prolific and so photosynthetic efficient
that it allowed the rest of the whole
Animal Kingdom and plant kingdom to grow
and develop to what we see and evolved
what we see today
in addition to that cyanobacteria are
really very important in photosynthesis
that we see around today because they
actually not only evolved the first
photosynthetic apparatus what happens
then is there was something called in
endosymbiosis and by endosymbiosis what
i mean is that there were other
organisms that took them up and when
they took them up they actually then
became part of that organism so in other
words the cyanobacterium was taken up by
a eukaryotic organism it carried out
photosynthesis that eukaryotic organism
really got its energy in some of its
sugar from that that organism that it
took up that sign of ancient
cyanobacterium and now it became a in it
lives now in symbiosis with him and
eventually what happened is that the
organism that became symbiotic with the
larger organism became so much a part of
it that they integrated together and
that Santa bacterium became what is now
known as the chloroplast for larger
plants so all oxygenic photosynthesis
essentially arose from the cyanobacteria
so whether you're a tree or grass you
have the same photosynthetic apparatus
as a cyanobacteria now the other thing
is that when when David and I first went
out into the world and talked about our
idea of cyanobacteria everybody just
assumed that we were talking about
little green slime which we were and
that little green slime is out they all
say it's algae well it isn't so Anna
bacteria are very different to now see
unfortunately in the early days
cyanobacteria were called blue-green
algae they're called blue green because
they look blue green but they're small
and they're not algae they're in a whole
different domain their bacteria and not
eukaryotic so I put up this little
little table here that essentially gives
an organism organismal comparison one's
a prokaryote that mean
that the cyanobacteria does not have a
nucleus as do algae they are bacteria
they're not LG or not plants but they
they are a whole different eukaryotic
system unto themselves the cyanobacteria
are really small whereas algae or large
Santa bacteria tend to be unicellular or
they grow in filaments that you can see
in a lot of places algae tend to be can
be uni or multicellular they both carry
out photosynthesis they both fix co2
that means that they are autotrophic
that they don't need any organic carbon
one of the big advantages for the type
of work that we do with cyanobacteria is
that they fix nitrogen that means you
don't have to fertilize they get their
nitrogen out of the air they can take n
2 and and transform it into ammonia and
use that ok whereas algae need to be
fertilized Santa bacteria are green
usually blue-green algae can be green
red or brown and they're quite different
and the habitats actually tend to be the
same they can live in the same areas
algae a little bit more finicky there
they're a little bit more particular
they're not as diverse as the
cyanobacteria and cyanobacteria tend to
reproduce vegetatively whereas algae can
reproduce sexually as well as
vegetatively now if we look at some of
the process comparisons that I have up
here you can see that usually when
people are working with organisms they
use them in a monoculture and a lot of
the biofuels and bioproducts that algae
are used that are used to make are used
by genetically modified organisms we in
our in our technology do not use
genetically modified organisms as at all
and I'll explain why in a minute now we
produce sugars algae don't really
produce sugars
algae produce lipids and those lipids
can be used as patrol as a substitute
for some petroleum-based things in
addition algae have a different kind of
cell wall so they have a plant like some
more like a plant cell wall where you
can actually harvest the biomass and get
sugars from the biomass because they
have they have sugars in their cell wall
and cyanobacteria do not and I spew this
up here strictly because again we get a
lot of questions about cyanobacteria
biomass why aren't you taking your
biomass why what do you do with the
biomass we go into people and we talked
them saying well we make sugar and the
sugar goes out into the solution and
they say well great what about the
biomass and I well we have to explain to
them that Santa bacteria are different
they don't have sugars in their cell
wall what they have is they have what's
called and I through this up here just
to illustrate it they have what's called
a peptidoglycan which is not cellulose
not sugars it's made up of this other
stuff that you see on the right side
what it is is they're essentially
peptides that link together an acetyl
muriatic acid and n-acetyl glucosamine
which are sugar like but they're not
sugars they are amino acids sugars far
cry from cellulose so they're really
quite different so I want to get the
point across that biomass is not really
that important to us as far as our
product is concerned what is important
and one of the things that we do is we
use echo mimicry you may have heard of
biomimicry which is essentially and
biomimetics which is an imitation of the
model systems and elements of nature to
solve complex problems but we do is echo
mimicry so what we do is we try to
really just mimic how a natural
ecosystem functions and that is really
what we wanted to do that's why we come
up one of the reasons why we came up
with this whole idea of a consortium
rather than a monoculture groans as one
organism
okay so what it really is is is putting
together our own type of ecosystem that
mimics nature there we go so what is our
technology basically we have very
limited say limited but a very small
supply chain all we really need is
seawater sunlight and air and our
organisms and that's it and from that we
produce sugars and I said earlier that
the organisms that we have are the most
photosynthetic that that in general
cyanobacteria the most
photosynthetically efficient organism
there is and they are and we've put
together a consortium of these
cyanobacteria that have the
characteristics of growing quickly they
have a short generation time and they're
very efficient at producing and
excreting sugars so here you see this
little table it may not mean much but
essentially I can say that we go from
what's called foetus and the actual
sunlight that organisms use which is
called par photosynthetically active
radiation which is the rate the spectrum
between 400 and 700 nanometers and they
can prove they can produce sugars at
about the over the percent level much
over the percent level whereas most
other organisms had a total when I say
most I mean like trees and grasses
including switchgrass and everything has
a photosynthetic efficiency an order of
magnitude less total photosynthetic
efficiency in order of magnitude less
that's the other reason why we chose
these organisms is because they're
energy efficient so basically to
summarize we take sunlight carbon
dioxide nitrogen from the air and sea
water which has all the micronutrients
and everything else in it that goes into
the cyanobacteria the cyanobacteria
produced fermentable sugars
and polysaccharides and we also have the
leftover cell of the cyanobacteria we
call that biomass but we use it for an
entirely different reason than other
technologies do so let's get a little
bit into the into the whole business
aspect of this now sugar as a commodity
is used in a lot of places industrially
as well as for food so this is raw sugar
price over the course of several years
so the sugar price has gone up and this
ends in about 2012 and the sugar demand
has gone up I will say that the sugar
demand has continued to grow but to
sugar price last year started to plummet
it's now down to 11 cents now you may
say Hawaii what did why did that happen
well and it's going to go back up
everybody predicts it's going to go back
up to over twenty cents a pound the
reason it fell because you have to pay
attention to international politics what
happened was sugar cane in Brazil the
price fell the price fell in sugarcane
in Brazil because the the whole economy
in Brazil was going through a change a
negative change I might add and so the
cost of their their money was not worth
as much since their money was not worth
as much the cost of the sugar cane on
the international market dropped as well
so that had a dramatic effect and
they're big producers of sugar that had
a dramatic effect on the cost of sugar
that's why it went down but its its
projected to go back up this green line
you see at the bottom that is our
projected price that we can sell it for
not a projected cost but a projected
price when I say cost that means cost of
production so our projected prices we
can go seven to ten cents a pound easily
if the price goes up there's no reason
why we couldn't raise our price up as
well and make a larger profit so we are
our whole business premise
is to produce low priced sugar for the
sugar market and our customers and that
means high customer margins that means a
greater profit margin for them in a
greater than 30 billion dollar market in
the united states alone okay so if we
take a look at what we have we have our
cyanobacteria okay we then grow the
cyanobacteria we separate the
cyanobacteria cells from the sugar
solution so we have a sugar solution we
d salen 82 sugar solution and if you
follow the cyanobacteria sugar feedstock
we have a polysaccharide that can go
directly to producing things such as
plastics or other polymers and by the
way i will say that we have recently
been successful in taking our
polysaccharide produced by our Santa
bacteria and making plastic from it on
the lab scale but we have demonstrated
that that can be done and then we take
the mono die and trisaccharides and
we've shown that they can be used by
other organisms to grow and to produce
other bio products so in other words
fermentation we've shown we can produce
ethanol butanol and other bio products
then we can take the residual biomass
and it can be used as fish food our fish
food supplement it can be used as a
fertilizer and it can be used in
anaerobic digesters to produce compost
or power now let's look at some
productivity comparisons between
cyanobacterial produced sugars and
sugarcane and corn now cyanobacteria I
said grow really really quickly and they
do and they produce a fair amount of
sugars so basically we have done granted
we haven't done it all the way to an
acre but we have shown on the basis of
larger than laboratory scale I will say
that and not in the confines of a clean
room outside in the real world we can
show that we should be able to produce a
hundred tons of
per acre per year now compare that to
sugarcane and corn sugar they produce on
the order of five tons of sugar per acre
per year so even if our hundred tons of
sugar per acre per year is way off by
fifty percent and we only produce 50
tons we're still an order of magnitude
better than they are now one of the
things that we always get asked is let's
so what about the energy density of
sugar and what can you really do with
sugar and how does it compare to other
things well that's why I threw this up
here if you look at the energy density
which is actually the the joules per
gram or mega joules per kilogram you see
that wood down there is on the order of
8 ethanol is on the order of 25 coal is
on the order of 30 oil is 40 and gas is
way up there about 52 or 53 well sugar
is 17 plain old glucose is 17 so plain
old glucose is right above wood and
below ethanol so if you're just going to
use sugar that gives you an energy
density comparison now what about
productivity comparison so if we look
here at productivity comparison in here
okay we're making sugar the world
doesn't necessarily always like to run
on sugar because it hasn't in the past
so if we try to compare it in looking at
ethanol per acre per year gallons of
ethanol per acre per year and you can
actually do that calculation because it
takes about 13 pounds of sugar to make a
gallon of ethanol we look at corn is way
down here in about 2 sugarcane is about
three and a half mccann 'this or not
three and a half sorry this is thousand
sorry okay we can't this comes next
algae is way up there but cyanobacteria
is way way up there and that's also
because they
grow so quickly and so
photosynthetically efficient there are
eight times the productivity of
miscanthus so we were fortunate enough
to be selected we apply for we were
selected by nrel a national renewal
Renewable Energy Lab in their end cap
what they call national
commercialization assistance program to
develop a techno-economic mind which
looks at the production and purification
of our Santa bacterial sugars to
estimate the key mass and energy
balances and to quantify associated
equipment capital and operating costs
that means centrifuges piping pumps
desalination do you need to add co2 how
much mixing how much energies are going
to take for the whole system and then
calculate an amendment a minimum sugar
price this system also has it calculates
as part of it biomass and production
ponds and what I mean propagation and
production ponds what we do and what is
done in the industry for algae and
everything else that you're trying
organisms like that that you're trying
to grow at large scale as you start out
small and then you go like from a leader
to five liters and then to 25 liters
then to 250 because you can't go from a
leader to 100 liters because what
happens is you have your population is
so dilute that it usually doesn't it's
not healthy it takes too long for it to
really take off and grow so you have to
make sure you have you have at least a
minimum amount of organisms that you go
from one stage to the next in addition
to that the speaking of propagation you
really want to make your organisms grow
quickly and outgrow anything else that
might be in there when you're talking
about large-scale operations commercial
scale operations if you can keep them
clean but it's very hard to keep them
sterile it can be done as it's done in
the pharmaceutical
industry but if you look at the price of
some of the pharmaceutical products
versus the price of what you might want
in a commodity market for biofuel to buy
our products there's a huge difference
so you pay a huge cost for keeping
everything sterile so you want to keep
it clean as possible but it's usually
not sterile so you want to have the
organisms in there in your system as
many of the ones that you want in there
and contaminants as low as possible and
you all your organisms to grow faster
and outgrow any contaminants that are in
there to make the product you want so
that's why when you propagate you
propagate in larger quantities until you
get to your production pond yes well
Buford a yes sorta actually if you go
through beer beer they propagate as well
it's propagated from a small amount to a
larger amount to large amount but
they're sterile they're fairly sterile
okay they have an enclosed system if you
ever go through a brewery you'll see
that it's fairly close but again the
cost of a beer is a lot more than a cost
of what you want for this for these bio
products yes if you get contaminated
beer it usually turns to vinegar malt
vinegar and that's not what you want but
yes so yes you're absolutely right there
they start with an enclosed system as
well ah so this model that NREL worked
up for us also looks at centrifugation
and solid separation to remove biomass
sugar recovery and purification
operations in other words desalination
primarily co-products and waste products
assigned our financial value by
co-products i'm talking about
essentially taking some of the biomass
using it for fish food as well okay now
as part of a techno-economic analysis
you do a life cycle analysis as leslie
mentioned before and she mentioned
greenhouse gas analysis that's the GHG
so what we have done here is we actually
had somebody who who does this for a
living is professional go through
roughly goes
to our system and look at it and see how
it would compare to a petroleum-based
system or gasoline and so we don't
really have any chemical or fertilizers
now we add so we r 0 we do have to
cultivate the system and so there is a
greenhouse gas emission equivalent
that's what's on the on the on the
x-axis there I mean the y-axis and so we
have some cultivation greenhouse gas
emission we have separation desalination
greenhouse gas emission we have some if
we're going to a biofuel we have the
product or sugars of our product of any
kind we have a greenhouse gas emission
transportation and delivery costs and
then we move up to combustion if we're
we're this was based on if we were
making a biofuel a combustion and so we
have a total of about 45 greenhouse gas
emission equivalents whereas you look at
petroleum gasoline you have about 95 so
in this rough estimate calculation of
greenhouse gas emissions cyanobacteria
actually are pretty good and one of the
reasons why they're really good is
because this first thing that says
chemicals and fertilizers we don't need
any most other things do and the cost of
producing fertilizers especially
nitrogen fertilizers is very very energy
intensive so I threw this in here
because one of the questions that I that
I got was market comparisons and
competitors who do we have as
competitors well hmm a main competitors
and people who would be our customers
now buy sugar from companies like a DM
Cargill and bungee and so what about
other companies that are sort of in the
market that produced things like sorghum
well there's a company called rogue
chromatin that will sell you the plants
for sorghum and they'll sell sell it to
you for about ten cent
a pound and then what about cellulosic
okay there are companies that are
entering the commercial phase that are
actually in the commercial phase I've
listed some of them here and breaking
down cellulose is not an easy
inexpensive thing to do so there are
companies like like Renault mattox that
uses supercritical water other companies
use acids so it's very difficult to
break down cellulose and it tends to be
expensive but it's happening the only
company that's out there that really
does something similar to us as a
company called Pro taro and they're an
early stage company and they use a sign
of bacteria that is genetically modified
to excrete sucrose and it's a fresh
water sign of bacteria so what they have
done is they have made it a very
efficient sucrose producing organism and
they have genetically modified it so
that they have a in the membrane a
sucrose membrane transporter that
whenever the sucrose is made inside the
cell it transports outside the cell now
I should say that they have also they
originally started in biofuels open
ponds they have progressed to where they
are now making nutraceuticals and other
things that sucrose could be used for
that's on a smaller scale and they use
an enclosed bioreactor so if we want to
look at our company and how do we
project our technology development from
the prototype to the pilot plant to the
commercial stage well basically we've
already got in place combining ourselves
with in partnering with moss landing
Marine Lab s RI and the a bpdu unit of
the Lawrence Berkeley Lab's to start a
small scale scale up to verify
productivity at doing some things
outside at the thousands of gallons
level and to do sugar analysis as well
as stability of our population the next
stage of course is
to go to the pilot stage and there we
target one acre we target one acre as
our commercial sized pond so instead of
having huge multi acre ponds what we
want is one acre pond that's duplicated
many many times we call a pond farm a
full-scale commercial pond farm and what
we based our our financial calculations
on is essentially we call it a five
thousand acre pond farm that really
consists of about forty six to forty
eight hundred acres of actual pond
including the propagation pond and then
the connecting roads and laboratory
laboratory and analyses area to go along
with so that's our competi we're really
starting out with a few thousand gallons
go to our pilot which is a one acre test
it out at one acre then commercial is to
multiply that one acre the other thing
that this really hinges upon as do all
other large-scale sugar production for
industrial purposes in John is that
there's colocation so your customers
have to be co-located with you that is
not anything new to us it's the industry
standard for example Solazyme which is
it's not a large company but they've
they're around in south san francisco
their actual production facility is not
here their production facility is in
iowa why because they buy their account
they buy their sugar from Adm which is
corn and so they're next to a corn sugar
production plan their co-located other
companies do the same thing so we would
have to do the same thing because it's
just too expensive to transport these
things all across the nation so this is
our big picture of an integrated coastal
bio refinery where we have our
cyanobacteria production we then go to
making our sugars which go into various
products by our partners
we actually then would partner with an
aquaculture for making for actually
purifying water and for Purdue producing
fish food I showed part of this to you
earlier but that's that's our big
picture of an integrated coastal
biorefinery when you get into this kind
of a system this also feeds into the
techno economic analysis so that you
don't have much in the way of waste
products you recycle as much of the
waste products as you possibly can so
that really is the end of the formal
part of the lecture however ah Leslie
sent me several questions that I think
are really good questions and I'll
answer some of them now so I'll answer
actually I'll answer all the questions
he sent me and then you can ask more so
someone asked what are the potential
environmental or bio hazards of
artificially growing the sign of
bacteria and I just wrote quick and
dirty answers there to remind myself
there really is none and the reason for
that is because these organisms are
naturally occurring so you find them
blowing around on the coast in the
coastal waters everywhere anyway the
only thing different we have done is
we've selected those organisms that can
grow together and do grow together and
grow together more efficiently
synergistically to produce sugars now so
there's nothing really strange about
this the only thing that we've done is
patented the way that we put in them
we've put them together and to allow
them to grow together that's all so
they're out there anyway so there's no
environmental bio hazard as far as
contamination really is concerned as
someone asked and that can the method
that we use be modified to desalinate
saltwater the answer to that yes because
the methods that are used are really
desalination methods that have been
adapted for us to use to take away the
sugar from the salt so there's nothing
new in that particular technology there
at all it's just standard desalination
type of technology we have
chosen to initially test microfiltration
and there's nothing new about that
either another question between
developing this new technique for
creating sugar in finding investors for
your company what was the most difficult
part you found in starting elio by
office iosys well one thing when we were
talking to investors we had a very
difficult time convincing them that
Santa bacteria are not algae and that
the problems that we have with sign of
bacteria are different than the problems
that you have with algae that for some
reason when we first got involved in
this we did not expect that but it has
been a problem and difficulty that we
know we have to face so we try to
explain it as best we can as we go along
we also try to explain that that as I
said earlier biomass everybody keys in
on biomass well cyanobacteria biomass is
quite different than algal biomass or
plant biomass in fact the do e has
specific calls out there for going from
to try to take biomass as they call
biomass algae trees switchgrass and
convert that to sugars we can't do that
because as I showed you our biomass
doesn't have regular sugars in it and so
trying to make people understand that
has also been something that we've had
to educate ourselves on how to educate
other people about and the other big
thing is de-risking people look or I
should say VCS look at a business and
one of the things they try to see is
what are all the risks and what are all
the big hurdles and have you passed them
yet and because there's been so much
work that has been done on algae and
trying to produce large quantities of
algae to produce biofuels of biomass in
open ponds it's been extraordinarily
difficult for them to do that so they
asked us to what is your scale up Sosuke
filling up is one of the biggest risks
that we have the thing that we have that
I did not mention as far as scale-up is
concerned is that when we use a
consortium of cyanobacteria echo mimicry
as I is is key and part of that means
that they are resistant to contamination
and to predation and they're being taken
over by other things coming around okay
why is that it's because it's a
community and the community is more
resistant inherently more resistant one
of the reasons that they make a
polysaccharide by the way is so that
they engulf this community in
polysaccharide and if you look at it
under a microscope you can see predators
trying to go after the cyanobacteria
neat them but you can't they can't
because they can't get through the
polysaccharide so that's one reason why
we've used this kind of technology is to
really protect our organisms from the
natural environment in the way that then
that organisms growing in the wild
protect themselves as well another
question as far as I antibacterial II
produced sugars goes this is certainly a
novel concept is there yes it is this
derek market for this kind of product
yes sugar basically is sugar
polysaccharides are polysaccharide
doesn't matter who makes them whether
they be made by cyanobacteria or whether
they be made by breaking down a tree
lignocellulose or cane sugar or corn
sugar sugar is sugar the thing that we
do that's different is we make a wider
variety of sugars not just one kind of
sugar but it's the sugar is not novel in
and of itself and who are your
competitors well I'm listening to
earlier things like companies as big as
a DM and Cargill to small companies such
as Pro taro okay what is the scalability
of this product a potential revenue of
this kind of work one acre pond well one
acre pond is our basic unit
we figure that we can using our one acre
pond is our basic unit one of the the
two most costly things to do with this
technology one has to do with
construction and that is a pond liner
believe it or not one acre pond liner
would cost on the order of nineteen to
twenty thousand dollars the other costs
that that really drives our production
up is desalination desalination of that
approximately seven to seven to eight
nine cents a pound desalination accounts
for a good portion of that what gross
good for the environment well it's we do
not compete with any anything that has
to do with food and we use non arable
land so those are just two things the
process that we use doesn't use
fertilizers we don't have to fertilize
we don't have to use any pesticides or
anything like that so in that regard
it's it's non-toxic and non
contaminating did your idea come out of
the Assam off East farms no it didn't
actually it did not it just came out of
us sitting around talking and figure how
can we most efficiently produce sugar
your website says that the bacteria use
our non-gmo why does this matter I
didn't say anything earlier because I
knew this question was coming up well
genetically modified organisms means
that you're taking them and you're
making them do something they don't want
to do so for example you're taking if
you genetically modify an organism to
produce a substance another organic
substance and excrete it I don't care
whether it's an extra sugar or
carbohydrate or a lipid or whatever its
excreting it that means it's not using
that for itself it means it's expending
energy to make it and excrete it so it's
not doing it any good so it doesn't like
to do that
so those organisms that are genetically
modified tend to not grow quite as well
the other thing that tends to happen is
especially when you start to scale up
it's very difficult to control the
population for a longer period of time
when you scale up what happens is
because these organisms don't like to do
what you're forcing them to do if
there's you have to put a selective
pressure on the population one of the
most common ways to do that is to take
an antibiotic we take an antibiotic
resistant gene hook it to the gene that
you're interested in to make your
product and then put that in the
organism and then put that out there and
then grow them in the presence of the
antibiotic so that the wild type doesn't
grow the only grows or your organisms
well you can imagine that doing that on
a large scale gets it's very difficult
and what happens is that the organism
that you've genetically modified fights
what you're trying to do and if it can
mutate back to the wild type it will and
it does so from a technical standpoint
using genetically modified organisms in
systems that you're not going to tightly
control because it costs so much money
is very difficult to do in addition to
that if you're out there in want to run
like a managed or even semi managed open
pond or even a large type bioreactor you
have and you're using genetically
modified organisms you've got to go
through a lot of regulatory issues you
have a lot of regulatory issues to deal
with so you have to you have to comply
with all the regulations that are out
there to not let your GMO out you know
so that doesn't get out in the wild
can't genetic modification be helpful
producing materials that are useful with
better yield and lower costs yes and in
fact it is done and in if you do it
right it can be very productive and very
good but in this certain in certain
circumstances it's not economically
efficient
or i it and it's so and the regulations
are too hard to comply with so we found
that for us and what we want to do we
didn't need any genetic modification so
we don't do it and I think that's oh
that's the last question our humans are
animals consuming a lot of what you
produce know our sugars are not produced
for human or animal consumption that
produced for other for yeast and other
bacteria to eat why so why should we
worried about the effects of the GMOs
and I think I alluded to that earlier
and that it's not a health effect
necessarily that we're talking about
we're talking about a technical effect
of there being so difficult to manage
regulatory issues and that's basically
the reason why you we want to stay away
from GMOs now are there any other
questions yes humans why can't humans
consume the sugars well you could if you
purified it we don't have to go through
such a high rate of purification for
just feeding other bacteria or yeast
it's just a purification and the only
reason why you don't do that is because
it costs money so we want to produce the
sugars at the very lowest cost of
production for industrial use
yeah glucose is glucose sucrose to
sucrose yes so in the life cycle
analysis desalination was the most
carbon intensive or the process yeah
because it takes a lot of yes because it
takes a lot of energy yeah have you guys
been researching ways produce yes there
are there yes and you know the whole
desalination aspect is probably one of
the I won't say riskiest but it is one
of the areas that we really have to
balance cost versus energy energy output
because their their their techniques out
there that would work really well and
not be so energy not not produce
greenhouse gases but they're very
expensive so it becomes a matter of
balancing the expense versus the
greenhouse gas production I mean in an
energy-intensive pneus is so it's one of
them and one of the problems as you may
or may not know is that if you for the
smaller sugars for the mono die and
tried saccharides the size of those on a
grand scale is not that much different
than the salts so it makes it more
technically difficult any other question
yes how sensitive are the pawns to
choose and weather conditions oh it's
not the ponds necessarily you're talking
about the organisms that was another
important factor in why we chose these
organisms that we did okay so what
happens if you have a pond doesn't even
have to be a big one and you put it out
there and it's a nun money unmanaged
just open pond several things happen one
is that all kinds of debris Falls in
another one is that the water evaporates
changing the salt concentration so what
you need then is you need and that's why
we say we use managed pond which means
that we put sort of like a screening on
top of it agree to keep so much debris
from falling in
the other thing that does is it helps
control the evaporation so but what if
you can't control the evaporation and in
your pond and what if you have a sudden
rainstorm unlikely is that it may be
here presently but what if you do you
change the salinity drastically so what
happens well if you don't have the right
kind of organisms and you change the
salinity they die both if it gets too
dilute when it gets to sailing so we
have chosen a group of organisms that
will withstand a large environmental
change in salinity essentially take them
down to physiological saline and they
won't like it but they don't die and
then put them back up to seawater which
is about three and a half percent and
they're fine now if you increase the
salinity too far like if you get it to
saturated salt they won't like that
either and they can die too the other
thing you have to look at is you have
and we've looked at this as well and
that is temperature ranges what happens
if the temperature gets too cold these
organisms don't really care if it gets
too cold they do care if it gets too hot
if you actually raise the temperature to
above 55 degrees C they're dead that's
all there is to it I will say that there
are cyanobacteria that will grow up to
72 degrees C but once you get past 72
degrees C no sign of bacteria grows
simply because at 72 degrees c you
hotter than that chlorophyll falls apart
so that's the temperature limitation
there but these are we think are pretty
good for what we want and then you have
to look at pH range changes and they
also have a wide tolerance for ph to
yeah yes oh sure so also the amount of
water that you live in that bridge I
would assume things you wouldn't
necessarily want to do it in a place i
mean i know that you were like a
sunlight for fuel but then you have a
large water resource requirements you
then ah the water comes from the ocean
so anything that we've talked about has
to be coastal so all you do is you have
a pipe that goes into the ocean and in
fact we use water from out from santa
cruz we've used moss landing water we've
used I mean to what happens is there's
there's their stations out there that
have pumps and Moss Landing Marine Lab
has one Santa Cruz UCSC has one out
there all they do is they have this big
pipe that goes out in the ocean they
have all the permits done and it goes
through a sand filter and that's the
water that we've used and that would be
the same way if you have a larger system
monterey blue water farms has the same
thing except on a larger scale because
they are they're growing fish in an
aquaculture situation here the
in the dark for days at a time if it's
really cloudy because there's a certain
ly cloudy is not dark these organisms
are photosynthetically efficient not
just when the sun's out but you can
reduce the or you can reduce the Sun to
one percent and they'll still
photosynthesize they're not happy but
they'll photosynthesize and they have to
go through a dark cycle so whenever we
that's the other thing whenever we grow
these if we got we have two ways of
growing them one is in the lab the other
ones outside the outside ones really
like it you know because they have a
natural diurnal cycle in the lab you
have to turn the lights on and off when
I say natural diurnal cycle that means
that the that the Sun comes up reaches a
peak and then it goes down and when it
because there's that's what their use
that's how they've evolved and so if you
look at the actual physiology and
metabolism of the organism during the
course of the day it's not the same it
changes especially around noon to one a
coal noon to two o'clock in the
afternoon noon to two o'clock in the
afternoon carbon diox-- ation goes way
down then it starts to come up again so
they like that and that has to do with
changes in the luminosity and the solar
flux so they actually like being out out
there in a natural environment so they
changed during the course of the day
being cloudy on a day or two that
happens in nature and that's really the
way these guys like to live yes
desalination is such a huge part of the
process and I know that there's a
company to in freshwater sound bacteria
would doing a fresh water sound bacteria
with a lower yields offset that
desalination so I had a bacteria at
fresh water sign of bacteria you
wouldn't have a lower yield who'd have
no yield unless you genetically modified
then you run into all the problems with
with a genetically modified organism yes
you have a remarkable history of growing
collaborations and you know being able
to co-locate with other operations where
you've been really leverage what kind of
guidelines are hints can you explain how
I'm you're so good at that I don't know
really I mean for example when we went
to when we approached the first the
first group do we approach was s RI ok
what we did is we approached them and so
they're basically their business and
nurse in their in their science group
and we just gave them presentation a
mostly technical presentation said look
this is what we have this is what we
want to do this is how we see you
fitting in with us how do you see
fitting in with us do would you like to
be part of this given that it's
high-risk and they said yes basically so
it's basically selling them on the
technology then for Moss Landing Marine
Lab for example they had they have a
group down there that and part of their
Charter is to work with small startup
companies who are doing the kinds of
things that we're doing if that small
startup company also will allow and has
the capability to work with graduate
students so you know when we talked with
him said you know we think that doesn't
be a great opportunity from a master's
thesis on this particular part of it and
we're fine with that and we can help
guide that you know and you have all the
technical you have all the
infrastructure and permanence and
everything to take water out of the
ocean and put it back and we have this
technology on cyanobacteria and growing
communities together you know is there
something we can do and the answer was
yes and when we approached Monterey
bluewater farms which is the aquaculture
company one of the problems that they
really have is when they put that water
back into the ocean they have to make
sure it's fairly clean one of the big
problems they have is with nitrogenous
waste from the fish I said that our
organisms fix nitrogen they do but they
also have the ability to eat nitrogen
out of the water if it's there so what
we propose to them is that our
cyanobacteria once we're through with
them we can put them in another tank or
pond and you can put your waste water
through it and they will then they'll
take out all the nitrogen and you can
put it back into the ocean without all
the nitrogen in it in addition it can
some of that can be used as a fish food
supplement and they thought that would
be a great idea to try because which
saves them a lot of money very systems
created you as you're looking at various
well you have we take the approach that
you really have to be a systems oriented
if you're going to actually make a
success out of it if you're just going
to do one small thing it's probably not
going to be successful that's why and I
went over this quickly but that's why we
put together this plan for an integrated
coastal biorefinery is to get everything
together to do as much as you can do
with what you have because if you don't
you're going to end up I think it's
going to be very very uh energy
inefficient and cost a fair amount of
money
haven't said lots about the bio plastics
but you've made demonstrations uh yeah
that's reason one of the things that
we've that we've done is we've looked at
the whole idea of taking the
polysaccharides and making bioplastics
out of them bioplastics you know come in
two categories they come in categories
that are not so biodegradable and they
come in categories that are
biodegradable even though they're all
bio plastics and so what we wanted to be
able to do is take our polysaccharide
which is biodegradable convert that to a
plastic to see if we can convert that to
a plastic and see if there might be uses
how hard would that be and how much
would that cost well we've teamed with
the a bpdu we have a grant from the DoD
OE to have the a bpdu essentially do
sugar analyses for us to polysaccharide
analyses polysaccharide deconstruction
look at calema nary production of bio
plastics look at more details as far as
using the sugars for various
fermentation reactions and so one of the
things that they've done is they have
taken our polysaccharide and have made
bioplastic out of it it's and one of the
n it seems to be a bioplastic that is
that is not too brittle which is good so
yes we've taken the first step in
showing that our polysaccharide without
really cleaning it even doing too much
to it they did a mild I'd they added
glycerine glycerine and did a mild acid
hydrolysis and produced a bioplastic
it's just a blob but it's plastic
yes so you said that you have to be
coastal which makes sense but coastal
land can be very expensive from
communication area that sort of thing so
like it's not a major course mijnheer
production costs or we have that has
taken we have taken that into account we
would not go to the coast of California
we would not use prime coastal land
because you can't afford it however if
you look at land across the world there
are coastal areas that are not that
expensive but it's work with strength up
where does because your customer that
has to do some shipping so it depends on
who your customer is but there are
places within not that far distance for
example if you were going to go across
the border into Baja they're out there
there are ponds there as a matter of
fact okay and so you just have to deal
with international shipping I also know
that there at Solazyme for example as is
in Brazil they're also amorous is in
Spain so you can go so it and there are
companies in Singapore all are slow and
be very expensive
there were there there's a group that
was looking still looking at looking at
growing algae offshore in essentially
closed bioreactor of bags and if you go
online and you look at project Omega you
can find it but it has some it has some
problems well it's expensive furniture
there a big amount of technical there
are a lot of technical problems yes well
the worst use of these sugars be to turn
them into something similar to gasoline
a petroleum replacement the work well
the easiest with the sugars what we do
is you treat it to an organism for
example that amorous has okay amorous is
a company in South San Francisco they
make something called farna scene okay
from far Nacene you can produce a
variety of biofuels so you take your
sugars and you feed it to their or you
sell it to them you feed it to their
organism they make the biofuels but
going but going directly or you feed it
to yeast to produce ethanol so you have
to feed it to someone or you feed it to
clostridium to produce butanol you have
to give it to some other organism to
produce actually the predecessor to the
fuel or the fuel itself well no actually
where I where we focus our efforts is
just producing the sugar do you want to
know oh the other thing that we do with
regard to for example the bio plastics
the other fermentation things we do is
to show the efficiency at which it can
be done and the process under which it
can be done and then go to other
companies to actually do it and say you
should use our polysaccharide to make
the plastic because it's more efficient
or whatever
you